in the 90s we had static websites in the
2000s we had WordPress and today we have
programmable content with content full
it works by treating all of your static
content like an API let's imagine your
product consists of an angular
progressive web app a native mobile app
and an electron desktop app contentful
serves as a centralized source for all
of your content so anytime something
changes you don't have to redeploy every
app individually in this episode I'm
going to show you how to use the
platform with an angular 5 progressive
web app and broadcast push notifications
out any time new content is published
before we get started I wanted to say
thank you to lifetime pro member frantic
they're building amazing enterprise
great apps using similar technologies to
what I show you here if you're looking
for inspiration for modern web app
development be sure to check out their
portfolio to get started with this
tutorial you'll need to first sign up
for a free content full account and the
first thing you'll do is create a space
for your content spaces allow you to
organize your concerns for example you
might have one space for blog post and
another space for product listings in
this example I'm going to create a
lesson space that will mirror the
content that you'll find on angular
firebase com the next step is to create
a content type so in this case our
content type is going to be a lesson but
you might also have content types for
the author profile or a category listing
or any other chunk of content that you
can imagine after you've created your
content type the next step is to add
some fields to it a field would be any
property related to your actual content
type so in this case we're going to set
a title field the beauty of this
platform is that you can standardize and
validate each field doing this from
scratch would be a ton of extra work for
a developer the end result is a
consistent blueprint for your content
that you can handle differently on any
platform after you have your blueprint
created you can then use content foulest
text editor to easily add new content
this is a powerful feature when you have
team members who create content for your
apps but aren't actually programmers so
your content creators get this text
editor and your programmers don't have
to worry about building one from scratch
that sums up the basic process for
building content with content full now
let's switch over to angular and action
use this in our progressive web app I'm
starting from a brand new angular app so
run ng new and then CD into the app and
then the only dependencies are content
full and a library called marked which
we're going to use to convert markdown
to raw HTML then to interact with the
API I'm going to create a service called
content fold and make sure to add that
to the app module from there go back
into content full and go to the API tab
then copy the space ID and the content
delivery token then you'll add these to
your environment TS file inside of
angular make sure that you're using the
content delivery token you don't want to
expose any API token that has right
access to your content 'full api from
here we're going to jump into the
service and the first thing we'll do is
import the content full sdk and we also
need the environment variables that we
just configured as well as the rxjs
observable class so the first thing we
need to do is initialize the sdk client
we do that by calling content full
create client along with our space ID
and our API token the first thing I want
to do is console log out the content
just so you know what the actual
JavaScript object looks like we can
retrieve a single piece of content which
in this case is our lesson by calling
client get entry with the entry ID
that's going to return a promise which
will resolve with the actual lesson
content that we want to use this method
I'm going to switch over to the app
component then I import the service and
I set up a variable here as an
observable that will hold our lesson
content here in the next step then we
can inject the service in the
constructor and during ng on an it will
call the method that we just defined
which will log the content in the
browser console each piece of content is
assigned a unique ID so I'm just copying
and pasting that is the argument to our
method if we load the app you see we get
the content here logged in the console
it has two main properties the fields
property is all of our content this is
the actual data that we want to show to
the user in the front end it corresponds
exactly to that field types that you
defined in content pool
it also has a system
which has some additional metadata about
the content you may or may not want to
use this depending on your particular
use case now that we know what the
content looks like let's convert it into
an observable so it's more angular
friendly so I'm creating a get content
method here which will first define the
promise in a variable it's calling the
same client get entry method with the
Content ID then we can convert it to an
observable by calling observable from
promise and then I'm going to map it
down just to the fields that's the
content that we want to show the end
user we don't really need that extra
metadata to make use of it I'm switching
back to the app component then I define
the lesson variable by calling this
method with the corresponding Content ID
now we can treat it like a regular
observable in the HTML if you're already
familiar with angular this code should
look very familiar to you
so first we'll unwrap the observable by
calling ng if and then use the async
pipe and then we'll set it to a template
variable called lesson from there it's
extremely easy to just call the lesson
properties directly on the object so
we'll display the lesson title then
created at timestamp is a JavaScript
date object so we can use the angular
date pipe to display that in a
user-friendly way the lesson tags are
saved as an array and content full so we
can loop over those tags using ng for
then the only issue we're going to run
into is when we display the lesson body
and I'll show you why here in just a
second here's what we have so far in
angular our title and our tags look
great but if you look closely at the
body it's written in markdown format
it's just a raw string instead of the
actual HTML that we want to display to
the user in the front end when you write
markdown it looks like this but angular
has no way of parsing this automatically
what we're going to do is create an
angular pipe called
MD to HTML and it's going to take
advantage of the marked library we
installed earlier to parse the markdown
to HTML first I'm going to go back into
the service and we're going to import
the marked library there I'm defining
this method in the service just to make
it a little more flexible to work with
so it just takes a markdown string as an
argument and then it calls the marked
library to convert it to HTML then we
can import the content full service
inside of our pipe and we'll inject that
into the
instructor just like we wouldn't a
component then all we have to do is take
the input value and call the method we
just created in the service on that
value then we can add the pipe to our
lesson body but it's still only going to
display a string so at this point we
just have a string of HTML code what we
can do is bind this to the inner HTML
property on a div this will render it as
actual HTML elements which is what we
want to display to the end-user but just
a quick warning you always want to make
sure that the source of the HTML comes
from a trusted location if users
generate this content you want to make
sure to sanitize it to avoid being
vulnerable to cross-site scripting you
can read more about this in the official
Docs if we go back into our angular app
you can now see that our links and our
headings are displaying like normal HTML
just like that we now have a powerful
content management system to organize
content in our progressive web app but I
did promise you one more thing and
that's sending push notifications
anytime new content is created in
content full I don't have time to show
you push notifications and to end but I
do have multiple lessons covering that
topic on angular firebase com what I am
going to show you is how to set up web
hooks in content full and then broadcast
notifications using firebase Cloud
messaging back in angular I have
firebase cloud functions initialized in
my project then I'm going to write a
function that uses the admin SDK we're
going to listen for web hooks from
contentful and when we receive one we're
going to parse it and then broadcast
messages out to a certain topic the web
hook is going to send us data whenever a
new lesson is published all of the
lesson details will be in the request
body so we can say request body fields
and the topic we want to send messages
to is lessons then we can use this data
to set the notification details so we'll
say a new lesson posted and then we'll
say angular firebase composted a new
lesson about whatever the lesson title
is and then we'll also add an icon to it
then we can call the firebase messaging
library and just call send a topic with
that notification payload if you lost at
this point make sure to check out some
of my firebase push notification videos
this is going to return a promise and if
it's successful then we can say
a successful response back to the
webhook if the message notifications
fail we can send an error response back
to content full of telling it to retry
the web hook if necessary and it's
really that simple all we have to do is
deploy the function then we'll go back
into content full and tell it when and
where to send the web hook after the
function deploy succeeds make sure to
copy and paste the URL that firebase
gives back to you then back in content
full you'll go into the space settings
and then to web hooks and then we'll
just give it a name of topic
notifications then copy and paste the
URL that firebase gave you back for that
cloud function then we only want to send
this web hook when new content is
published so we can do that by going
down to only selected events and then
click the box that intersects entry and
publish you can verify that the web hook
works by going back into the content tab
and then create a new piece of content
after that you can go back to the web
hooks screen and you should see a
successful response from the cloud
function it will show you the web hook
body that was sent by content full and
then show you the response that was
received from firebase that's it for
angular 5 with content pool if this
video helped you please like and
subscribe and if you want to learn more
advanced features of progressive Web
Apps consider becoming a pro subscriber
at angular firebase comm you'll get a
free copy of my book as well as one on
one project support thanks for watching
and I'll see you next time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]